I'm a huge fan of your work which you
know you are so driven to contribute to
the community and the places in which
your work shows up and what I
particularly love is you're leading this
movement to make the world a little more
un boring things being boring isn't just
boring it's actually like a cultural
revolution that's stripping us actually
of our Humanity I think we all know
there are huge challenges ahead and
without Joy you can't solve problems
unless you have hope and optimism and
that's why I was looking forward to
talking to you as well because I know
actually underneath it all your big
Drive is to find that hope and culture
to me is is actually it is hope that's
what it is